Hello, welcome to a very special bonus episode of How We Made Your Mother.
大家好，欢迎收看《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的特别奖励剧集。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
Hey, we are doing an episode that we like to call general questions.
嘿，我们正在制作一集，我们喜欢称之为一般性问题。
General questions.
一般问题。
It was alright.
没关系。
We keep trying to sync up the salutes and it's just not gonna happen.
我们一直在努力同步敬礼，但这是不可能的。
It's not gonna happen.
这不会发生。
I'll tell you why it's not working.
我会告诉你为什么它不起作用。
Just because we have the ever so slice.
只是因为我们拥有如此多的切片。
We have a delay on the on the yeah, so I think our live show, when we do a live show, it's going to be.
是的，我们有延迟，所以我认为我们的现场表演，当我们进行现场表演时，它将会是。
Let's do it right on the live show, please.
请让我们在现场表演中做到这一点。
We have to do a live show just for that one thing.
我们必须做一场现场表演只是为了这一件事。
And let's hope that the audience thinks up with us, like we should get however many people are.
我们希望观众能和我们一起思考，就像我们应该得到的那样，无论有多少人。
We are discussing the television program, how I met your mother, which ran on CBS from 2005 to 2014.
我们正在讨论 2005 年至 2014 年在哥伦比亚广播公司 (CBS) 播出的电视节目《我是如何遇见你的母亲》。
The episode under consideration this week, which we talked about a couple of days ago, is Mary the Paralegal, written by Chris Harris.
本周我们正在考虑的剧集是克里斯·哈里斯（Chris Harris）撰写的律师助理玛丽（Mary the Paragalal）。
That was episode 18.
那是第18集。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
A 19, marry the paralegal episode 19.
19、嫁给律师助理第19集。
Nothing good happens after 2 a.m.
凌晨两点之后就没有什么好事发生了。
was episode 18, yes?
是第18集，是吗？
I think so.
我想是的。
Okay, so this is, we'll see.
好的，就是这样，我们拭目以待。
I've seen the show and someone will correct us for sure if we're wrong.
我看过这个节目，如果我们错了肯定会有人纠正我们。
But marry the paralegal, super funny episode with some real touching moments.
但是，将律师助理的超级有趣的情节与一些真实感人的时刻结合起来。
But let's hear what people had to say about this episode, what they want to go deeper on.
但让我们听听人们对这一集的看法，以及他们想深入探讨的内容。
Yeah.
是的。
What do you got for us, Alec?
你给我们准备了什么，亚历克？
Well, many people point that, of course, a very important catchphrase and that Jenny Finn 22 wants to know who came up with Loyard.
嗯，很多人指出，这当然是一个非常重要的口号，Jenny Finn 22 想知道是谁想出了 Loyard。
It became such a great himium catchphrase, definitely one of my favorites.
它成为了一个伟大的流行语，绝对是我的最爱之一。
Boy, I can't remember.
男孩，我不记得了。
I don't know.
我不知道。
Maybe it was me.
也许是我。
Maybe it was Carter.
也许是卡特。
Maybe it was Chris Harris.
也许是克里斯·哈里斯。
I don't.
我不知道。
I can't remember.
我不记得了。
There's a lot.
有很多。
It's funny.
很有趣。
There's certain jokes from like, I can picture where the writer or I was when they pitched that joke.
有一些笑话，比如，我可以想象当他们提出这个笑话时，作者或我在哪里。
You know, like, I remember I said half an ad, but then that other person said that thing that made it even better.
你知道，就像，我记得我说了半个广告，但后来另一个人说了那句话，这使得它变得更好。
And other ones where I'm like, I don't know, it's just one of those mysteries.
还有一些我觉得，我不知道，这只是这些谜团之一。
You know, also when you're co-writing, like, Ben Lee and I wrote a bunch of songs together, made two albums together, there's a song of all of us called Down in the Dirt.
你知道，当你共同创作时，比如，Ben Lee 和我一起写了很多歌曲，一起制作了两张专辑，有一首我们所有人的歌叫做《Down in the Dirt》。
And it's one of, I came in with the chorus actually, but the rest of the song, it's quite an epic song.
这是其中之一，实际上我是随着副歌进来的，但歌曲的其余部分，这是一首史诗般的歌曲。
I remember the day we were sitting in my living room and I remember we were, we caught a wave.
我记得那天我们坐在客厅里，我记得我们抓住了海浪。
we were just going back and forth, and I don't remember who came up with what lyric at all in this song.
我们只是来来回回，我根本不记得这首歌的歌词是谁想出来的。
I just know that we were constantly leapfrogging over the other person's idea, refining the other idea.
我只知道我们不断超越对方的想法，完善对方的想法。
And in some ways, that's kind of evidence of a great collaboration is like, it's a Mobius strip.
在某些方面，这是伟大合作的证据，就像莫比乌斯带一样。
Like, I don't know where one thing ends and the other begins.
就像，我不知道一件事从哪里结束，另一件事从哪里开始。
Yeah, I think that's the dream.
是的，我想这就是梦想。
And I think that's a kind of creative flow that it's like for writers room or songwriting team gets into that you'd like don't you almost don't want to question it it's oh I almost have magical thinking about it where it's like you almost don't want to pick apart how it happened it just happened but you know what's funny didn't you say that a bunch of lawyers have come up to you and said in law school they would sing to themselves be your lawyer headband yes and say lawyer we've had a bunch of lawyers yeah I started saying that yeah you don't have to be a lawyer to say lawyer that's what's fun because it's it's a very democratized idea of like, you win an argument, you can just go lawyer, you know?
我认为这是一种创造性的流程，就像作家室或歌曲创作团队进入的那样，你不想质疑它，哦，我几乎对它有神奇的思考，就像你几乎不想分解它是如何发生的，它就这样发生了，但你知道有趣的是，你不是说一群律师来找你并说在法学院他们会唱歌给自己做你的律师头带是的并说律师我们有一群律师，是的，我开始说，是的，你不必成为一名律师才能说律师，这很有趣，因为这是一个非常民主化的想法，比如，你赢得了一场争论，你可以去当律师，你知道吗？
Yeah, our good friend, Noah Garrison, was an easily, you know, he was an environmental lawyer.
是的，我们的好朋友诺亚·加里森（Noah Garrison）是一位轻松的环境律师。
He went to school for first geology, then law school, then combine them with the environmental lawyer.
他首先在学校学习地质学，然后在法学院学习，然后将它们与环境律师结合起来。
And now he teaches law at UCLA through that lens.
现在他通过这个镜头在加州大学洛杉矶分校教授法律。
And as all, you know, in some ways, all of it goes back to basing the character on our good friend.
总而言之，你知道，在某些方面，这一切都可以追溯到我们好朋友的角色。
I keep, I'm looking at Alec, I'm addressing this Alec as Noah is Alex, one of his oldest friends, right?
我继续说，我看着亚历克，我称呼这个亚历克为诺亚是亚历克斯，他最老的朋友之一，对吧？
You went to So elementary school with him and the honor that we can do.
你和他一起上过小学，我们很荣幸。
Oh, no, we went to daycare.
哦，不，我们去了托儿所。
We were three.
我们当时三岁。
And then I met you guys at Wesleyan.
然后我在卫斯理安认识了你们。
You both went to Wesleyan together.
你们一起去了卫斯理安。
You guys did your entire education together.
你们一起完成了整个教育。
And then we honored Noah with the profession, Marshall's profession.
然后我们以马歇尔的职业向诺亚致敬。
And I was going to ask, I can't remember.
我正想问，我不记得了。
Is that where being a lawyer?
这就是当律师的地方吗？
Is that where the church came from?
教会是从那里来的吗？
I just took Noah's.
我刚拿了诺亚的。
I took Noah's, I probably, I hope I asked Noah's permission.
我拿了诺亚的，我可能，我希望我征得了诺亚的许可。
I'm notorious for just telling people after I did these things and not remembering to ask them, but I think I asked Noah and certainly he was delayed in either way that it was based on based on him.
我因在做完这些事情后只告诉人们而不记得问他们而臭名昭著，但我想我问了诺亚，当然他以任何方式延迟了，这是基于他的。
Do you know what's funny is sometimes you make these decisions like professions or even surnames, right?
你知道有趣的是有时你会做出这些决定，比如职业甚至姓氏，对吗？
That are kind of quick, you just like, that'll do, right?
这有点快，你只要喜欢，就可以了，对吧？
Like, Marshall's a lawyer or Ted's an architect or I remember the day Ted had his last name.
比如，马歇尔是一名律师，或者泰德是一名建筑师，或者我记得泰德有他的姓氏的那一天。
I remember from, I think the pilot, but not everyone had their last name.
我记得，我想是飞行员，但不是每个人都有姓氏。
Barney didn't have a last name.
巴尼没有姓氏。
I don't know if anyone else had a last name, but I remember it was Robin did I think in the news yeah Yeah, but you guys came in with the other three last names and kind of assign them and I remember one it like Barney Stinson sounded like strange like it sounded like I don't know is that right?
我不知道是否还有其他人有姓氏，但我记得是罗宾，我在新闻中认为是的，是的，但是你们带着其他三个姓氏进来并分配了它们，我记得一个像巴尼·斯廷森（Barney Stinson）听起来很奇怪，就像我不知道是这样吗？
But you named him after the replacements which which replacement with the bass player of the replacement the replacements Tommy Stinson Tommy Stinson Carter huge huge replacement span Carter Bay is who made me into a huge replacements fan and Carter Carter So that's let's honor a Stinson just a cool cool weird.
但是你以替补球员的名字命名了他，其中替补球员的贝斯手汤米·斯廷森（Tommy Stinson）汤米·斯廷森·卡特（Tommy Stinson Carter）巨大的替补跨度卡特湾（Carter Bay）使我成为了一个巨大的替补球迷和卡特·卡特（Carter Carter）所以让我们向斯廷森致敬，只是一个很酷很酷的怪人。
Yeah, they're weird like not super.
是的，他们很奇怪，但并不超级。
Yeah, Eric's in Aldrin these kind of they all end in some They kind of do there's a look lately.
是的，埃里克（Eric）在奥尔德林（Aldrin），这些都以某种形式结束，他们最近好像有一些。
We like that that phoneme That particular phoneme sound but they but they you might have made these these assignments of names and occupations You kind of can make them a little flippantly like even if it's a placeholder and then suddenly nine years on you're like Lily Aldrin Barney Stinson Marshall Erickson like they sound like properly famous people like they're like they're like They couldn't be another name and it's kind of funny because you're like oh, there's just these made-up names Then you go like every other fucking That's right, you know why we named Lily Aldrin Lily Aldrin right was it Buzz Aldrin we so Carter and I wrote multiple pieces for Buzz Aldrin on when we wrote for Dave Letterman.
我们喜欢那个音素那个特定的音素听起来但是他们但是他们你可能已经做了这些名字和职业的分配你可以让它们有点轻率地喜欢即使它是一个占位符然后突然九年后你就像莉莉奥尔德林巴尼斯汀森马歇尔埃里克森他们听起来像真正的名人就像他们就像他们不可能是另一个名字这有点有趣因为你就像哦，只有这些编造的名字 然后你就像其他他妈的一样 那是的，你知道为什么我们命名莉莉·奥尔德林 莉莉·奥尔德林 对吧 是巴兹·奥尔德林 我们所以卡特和我在为戴夫·莱特曼写作时为巴兹·奥尔德林写了多篇文章。
We did these pieces where we have Buzz Aldrin, it'd be like astronaut on the roof, astronaut on the cab.
我们在巴兹·奥尔德林的帮助下制作了这些作品，就像屋顶上的宇航员，驾驶室上的宇航员。
And he would clearly, he would seem slightly deranged because he'd be like, hi Dave, I'm up here on the roof.
显然，他看起来有点精神错乱，因为他会说，嗨戴夫，我在屋顶上。
Look what happens when I hit a golf ball and he just had a golf ball to just sort of trickle off.
看看当我击打高尔夫球时会发生什么，而他只是有一个高尔夫球可以滴下来。
Isn't that amazing?
这不是很神奇吗？
He thought he was on the moon.
他以为自己在月球上。
He thought he was just acting like everything was like, I'm holding up this pen.
他以为他只是表现得好像一切都像，我拿着这支笔。
Watch what happens when I drop and the pen would just drop.
观察当我掉落时会发生什么，笔就会掉落。
And we did all these bits.
我们做了所有这些工作。
And then it became this weird thing where we had him, We had Buzz Aldrin as the Late Show correspondent for the Daytime Emmy Awards.
然后事情就变得很奇怪了，我们让巴兹·奥尔德林担任日间艾美奖深夜秀记者。
And we went, Carter and I, with Buzz Aldrin, dressed in astronaut, dressed as an astronaut in full astronaut theater.
我们，卡特和我，还有巴兹·奥尔德林，穿着宇航员的衣服，打扮得像个宇航员，在完整的宇航员剧院里。
We had to walk from Late Show at Sullivan Theater to Radio City for the Daytime Emmy Awards, where like soap opera stars are beginning being given awards.
我们不得不从沙利文剧院的深夜秀步行到无线电城参加日间艾美奖颁奖典礼，就像肥皂剧明星一样开始颁奖。
And he had a microphone and he was on the red carpet in an astronaut outfit.
他带着麦克风，穿着宇航员装走在红地毯上。
And he was saying like, hey, you know, are you, are you proud to be nominated for Best Supporting actor on a daytime soap and they'd be like, Oh, yeah, it's my first nomination.
他说，嘿，你知道，你是不是很自豪能够获得日间肥皂剧最佳男配角的提名，他们会说，哦，是的，这是我的第一次提名。
I'm really proud of you.
我真的为你感到骄傲。
Be like, Oh, cool.
就像，哦，酷。
Um, I walked on the moon.
嗯，我在月球上行走过。
And it's just would give people shit that his achievement.
他的成就只会让人们大吃一惊。
That's a real that's a definition of a good sport right there.
这才是真正的好运动的定义。
Yeah, that's really, you must be proud.
是的，确实是这样，你一定很自豪。
I did walk on the moon though.
不过我确实在月球上行走过。
Um, and it was just, and we had Buzz Aldrin as an astronaut doing this weird shit all the time.
嗯，这只是，我们让巴兹·奥尔德林作为一名宇航员一直在做这种奇怪的事情。
And so we thought to ourselves when, and he was really good sport about it and And he's funny, and we thought we would one day get him, we would reveal that Lily's grandfather was Buzz Aldrin and cast him to be, oh, never met your mother.
所以我们心里想，他真的很有趣，而且他很有趣，我们认为有一天我们会得到他，我们会透露莉莉的祖父是巴兹·奥尔德林，并让他扮演，哦，从未见过你的母亲。
As Lily's grandfather.
作为莉莉的祖父。
And we pitched it, and we asked it, and somehow it did not come together.
我们提出了它，我们询问了它，但不知怎的，它没有走到一起。
I don't, it was a polite pass.
我不知道，这是一次礼貌的通行证。
We thought we could call in our late show Goodwill, and we were but we were a new enough show, maybe didn't know what it was.
我们以为我们可以把我们的晚间节目称为“善意”，我们确实这么做了，但我们是一个足够新的节目，也许不知道它是什么。
He's like, I will not be humiliated.
他说，我不会被羞辱。
I think you really enjoyed doing the weird stuff for Lecho, but I don't know what happened.
我认为你真的很喜欢为 Lecho 做这些奇怪的事情，但我不知道发生了什么。
It didn't come together.
它没有走到一起。
And then we're like, well, that's a cool last name anyway.
然后我们就想，好吧，无论如何，这是一个很酷的姓氏。
Yeah.
是的。
So she's really older.
所以她真的老了。
And that's what clearly buzz is in the family tree of Lily.
这就是莉莉家谱中显而易见的话题。
Yeah, he's somewhere.
是的，他在某个地方。
I still believe he's still alive.
我仍然相信他还活着。
Yeah, we just didn't get it.
是的，我们只是没明白。
Josh, I feel like you and I talked about this once.
乔希，我觉得你和我曾经讨论过这个问题。
It was a script we were working on wherever it was, the idea that you write a character into a script and then you just cut them.
无论在什么地方，我们都在制作这个剧本，这个想法是将一个角色写进剧本，然后你就可以剪掉它们。
And then like, there's this feeling of like, that's a whole actor.
然后就像，有一种感觉，那就是一个完整的演员。
A whole actor just didn't get cast in that role and didn't get to be in that movie.
一个完整的演员没有被选入那个角色，也没有参加那部电影。
Cause you just went, nope.
因为你刚刚走了，不。
That's a weird, it's a weird amount of power in those early days, like naming someone.
这很奇怪，在早期，这是一种奇怪的力量，就像给某人命名一样。
Oh, the first on camera job I got was this show called Now and Again.
哦，我得到的第一份摄影工作是这部名为《Now and Again》的节目。
There was a show called Once and Again and Now and Again, like in 1999 or 2000.
有一个节目叫《Once and Again》和《Now and Again》，比如 1999 年或 2000 年。
And it was the first on camera job I got.
这是我得到的第一份摄影工作。
There were two roles that I was reading for it.
我正在为它阅读两个角色。
And I got the bigger role, right?
我得到了更重要的角色，对吗？
a bigger role.
发挥更大的作用。
And they were going to pay me, I think, $800 to do it at the time, a lot of money.
我想他们当时会付给我 800 美元来做这件事，很多钱。
And I woke up, either the morning of doing it or the morning before, got a call from my agent and said, well, the rewrite came through and that character is not in there.
然后我醒来，要么是在做这件事的早上，要么是前一天早上，接到我的经纪人的电话，说，好吧，重写完成了，那个角色不在那里。
But she said, good news, they're still paying you.
但她说，好消息，他们还在付钱给你。
So I got the 800 bucks.
于是我就拿到了800块钱。
But I was unable to to do it, you know?
但我没能做到，你知道吗？
But yeah, no, I mean, you become, you become the, what is the phrase from the Bhagavad Gita that Oppenheimer says?
但是，是的，不，我的意思是，你成为，你成为，奥本海默所说的《薄伽梵歌》中的这句话是什么？
Like, I am death, what is it like, I am the story.
就像，我就是死亡，那是什么样子，我就是故事。
I did not foresee you bringing that exactly.
我没有预见到你会带来那个。
But you become the master of this universe where like you can kill characters, you can resurrect them, you can, and also when you add a character, you've just given an actor a day player.
但你成为了这个宇宙的主人，你可以杀死角色，你可以复活他们，你可以，而且当你添加一个角色时，你刚刚给了一个演员一天的播放时间。
I say you create life, you also create life.
我说你创造生命，你也创造生命。
You create life, yeah, so.
你创造了生命，是的，所以。
create Aldrin's and Eric's instance.
创建奥尔德林和埃里克的实例。
Just as in the next episode, Craig, you created life.
就像下一集中一样，克雷格，你创造了生命。
You created it as a preview for next Monday's episode.
您将其创建为下周一剧集的预览。
Is this my cameo?
这是我的客串吗？
No, this is my cameo.
不，这是我的客串。
Oh, right, right, right.
哦，对了，对了，对了。
The next one.
下一张。
Forget about my cameo.
忘了我的客串吧。
Yes, that's right.
是的，没错。
This is a teaser for Alan's new moment.
这是艾伦新时刻的预告片。
Tune in on next Monday after this, right?
在此之后的下周一，对吧？
This will be the Monday after this for Alan's huge moment.
这之后的下周一将是艾伦的重要时刻。
All right, enjoy that.
好吧，享受吧。
I just wanted to be able to get the talk about it.
我只是想能够谈论它。
Over the course of two episodes, not just one.
一共两集，而不是一集。
Is this going to be the flip for social media?
这会成为社交媒体的翻转吗？
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
您可能是在 Bravo's Summer House 认识我的，但在我的播客 More Life 中，我会不分昼夜地邀请您最喜欢的真人秀明星进行您通常听不到的对话。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
深层的东西，脆弱的东西，不舒服的东西。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我与塞拉·米勒 (Sierra Miller)、德林达·梅德利 (Derinda Medley)、汤姆·施瓦茨 (Tom Schwartz)、林赛·哈伯德 (Lindsey Hubbard) 等人进行了交谈。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们在成长过程中会陷入人际关系，遇到混乱的事情，以及摄像机不转动时发生的一切。
New episodes of more life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每周都有新剧集讲述更多生活，无论您在哪里收听播客或在 YouTube 上观看。
Okay.
好的。
Abhajai Prakash asks, please tell me about how you guys arrived with the idea of telepathic conversations.
阿巴贾伊·普拉卡什 (Abhajai Prakash) 问道，请告诉我你们是如何想到心灵感应对话的想法的。
I love them.
我爱他们。
I believe them.
我相信他们。
I have them all the time with myself.
我一直把它们带在身边。
I'm not sure if that's the same idea.
我不确定这是否是同样的想法。
I also believe this is the first episode to do that.
我也相信这是第一集做到这一点的。
Everyone's in sync to Marshall, Marshall, and Lily.
每个人都与马歇尔、马歇尔和莉莉保持同步。
That letter's from Abby.
那封信是艾比寄来的。
Josh and Alec and I are, we're all having a telepathic conversation right now going, that's not telepathy.
乔什、亚历克和我，我们现在正在进行心灵感应对话，那不是心灵感应。
What I said isn't telepathy.
我说的不是心灵感应。
No, look, every friend group has telepathy, right?
不，你看，每个朋友群都有心灵感应，对吧？
I, you know, it's just, and my favorite part of this, you can communicate, right?
我，你知道，这就是我最喜欢的部分，你们可以交流，对吧？
With your eyes to a really close friend, you can make a bit, you can do a whole riff with somebody, never say a word.
当你的目光投向一个真正亲密的朋友时，你可以做一些事情，你可以和某人一起即兴表演，而不说一句话。
My favorite moment of this is that Lily really hears Marshall's thoughts.
我最喜欢的时刻是莉莉真正听到了马歇尔的想法。
Like I really love that there's a supernatural, like we just break the road, we say like she actually is hearing these thoughts, it's not just the, like it really happened.
就像我真的很喜欢有一种超自然现象，就像我们刚刚打破了道路，我们说就像她实际上正在听到这些想法一样，这不仅仅是，就像它真的发生过一样。
That's my favorite moment, maybe.
也许那是我最喜欢的时刻。
Well, you know, also like when you're having that telepathy, and I think it happens with couples a lot where you can't wait to get in the car afterwards to actually give voice to the telepathy you were having?
嗯，你知道，就像当你拥有心灵感应时一样，我认为这种情况经常发生在情侣身上，你迫不及待地想上车后真正表达出你所拥有的心灵感应？
Yes, and be like, where are we having that conversation?
是的，就像，我们在哪里进行对话？
We were, I knew it.
我们是，我知道。
That's what you were thinking.
这就是你的想法。
Yeah, that's the best.
是的，这是最好的。
It's very satisfying.
这是非常令人满意的。
And that's the gift, right?
这就是礼物，对吗？
That's the gift of a great partner, a great friend.
这是一位伟大的合作伙伴、一位伟大的朋友的礼物。
But it's also, I think we talked about this on the episode, but it's such a good, it's a hilarious bit, like the opportunities to mind comedy, and you didn't go to the well too much.
但我想我们在这一集里也讨论过这一点，但它太棒了，有点搞笑，就像有机会介意喜剧，而且你没有去井太多。
I don't think we overused it.
我不认为我们过度使用它。
I think we could have used it more.
我认为我们可以更多地使用它。
I couldn't usually board to be honest.
老实说，我通常无法登机。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I love it so much.
是啊是啊，我太喜欢了。
It's such a weird shot to like the extreme closeup of somebody's face.
喜欢某人脸部的特写镜头真是太奇怪了。
Like it makes you realize like, you don't go to those closeups for comedy very often, right?
就像它让你意识到，你不会经常去看那些喜剧特写，对吧？
Maybe it's very sort of soap operatic to be that tight on somebody's face and a TV show.
也许对某人的脸和电视节目如此紧张就像肥皂剧一样。
And it's like, it's just bracing.
就像，这只是支撑。
It makes you lean forward and pay attention.
它让你身体前倾并集中注意力。
And the fact that you're acting to your own voiceover, Josh would have pre-recorded his voiceover and he's acting to his voiceover as Pam pointed out that it really played great.
事实上，你是在按照自己的画外音表演，乔什会预先录制他的画外音，而他正在按照他的画外音表演，正如帕姆指出的那样，效果真的很棒。
I worked, as I've mentioned before, as my biggest name dropped, but I did this show Hunters Without Pachino for two years, and I had this big scene with him where he had a lot of dialogue, and I was kind of coked up and spent on the floor, like we're on the bed listening to him.
正如我之前提到的，随着我的大名鼎鼎，我工作了，但我为这部剧《没有帕基诺的猎人》做了两年，我和他一起拍了一个大场景，他有很多对话，我有点兴奋，躺在地板上，就像我们在床上听他说话一样。
And I character was.
而我的性格就是。
Yeah, my character wasn't, I'm talking about the way I came in to film, but we, I asked him on either the day we were shooting or the day we were rehearsing, I said, well, how do you think of scenes where you're mostly wordless?
是的，我的角色不是，我说的是我进入电影的方式，但是我们，我在拍摄当天或排练当天问他，我说，好吧，你如何看待大部分无言的场景？
where you don't have dialogue.
没有对话的地方。
How do you approach those scenes?
你如何处理这些场景？
And he said, never stop thinking.
他说，永远不要停止思考。
He said, the camera loves thought.
他说，相机热爱思考。
So even if you were going over your grocery list, don't catch the camera.
因此，即使您正在查看购物清单，也不要拍摄相机。
Don't have the camera catch you when you're blank.
当你一片空白时，不要让相机拍到你。
Always be thinking something.
总是在想一些事情。
Because the camera loves watching thought.
因为相机喜欢观察思想。
And there's something about those close-ups where it's like, it's film acting.
这些特写镜头有点像电影表演。
Normally you don't get the closed caption or whatever, like the voiceover.
通常，您不会看到隐藏式字幕或其他内容，例如画外音。
where it's telling you what that, but the comedy comes from, I'm acting out with my eyes, and little eyebrow twitches, and nostril flares, and smirks, or whatever, of what the character's thinking.
它告诉你那是什么，但喜剧来自于，我用我的眼睛、小眉毛抽搐、鼻孔张开、傻笑，或者其他什么来表现角色的想法。
So it's almost like the purest expression of cinematic acting, which is, you know, I asked a friend who's a director, like, what is great film acting?
所以这几乎就像电影表演最纯粹的表达，你知道，我问一位导演朋友，什么是伟大的电影表演？
And he said, when the audience understands the thoughts of the character without them having to say a word.
他说，当观众不需要说一句话就能理解角色的想法时。
Yeah, what great acting advice, And like just thinking of like dog day afternoon, thinking of like Pacino's great performances, like he's never not alert, like in the movie like dog day afternoon, like all he's like, he's so much electricity behind the eyes.
是的，多么好的表演建议啊，就像想想《三伏天的下午》，想想帕西诺的精彩表演，就像他从来没有不警觉，就像电影《三伏天的下午》一样，就像他的样子，他的眼睛后面充满了电流。
So much electricity behind his eyes.
他的眼睛后面充满了电流。
Yeah, it's a great acting node.
是的，这是一个很棒的表演节点。
Okay, turns out he's good.
好吧，事实证明他很好。
He may be a good actor.
他可能是一个好演员。
I know that Josh, you've become friends with Rob Reiner.
我知道乔什，你已经和罗布·莱纳成为朋友了。
Do I have that correct from some?
我从某些人那里得到的信息正确吗？
Yeah, yeah, I did a pilot with him the year before I did how I met your mother and we stayed in touch over the years.
是的，是的，在我拍摄《如何遇见你母亲》的前一年，我和他一起拍摄了一部试播集，这些年来我们一直保持着联系。
So all in the family, check it out.
所以一家人都来看看吧。
the rare sitcom with serious close-ups, like serious close-ups.
罕见的带有严肃特写镜头的情景喜剧，就像严肃的特写镜头一样。
Yeah, drama close-ups.
是的，戏剧特写。
It's very odd to see, but obviously it works.
看起来很奇怪，但显然它是有效的。
Okay, so many other things here.
好吧，这里还有很多其他的事情。
Here's just a little detail.
这里只是一个小细节。
People are interested in the use of brands on screen.
人们对屏幕上品牌的使用感兴趣。
Keenan99 says, I know brands will frequently be blurred out or covered up or redesigned on certain TV shows.
Keenan99 说，我知道某些电视节目中的品牌经常会被模糊、掩盖或重新设计。
This seems to happen occasionally on Hemium.
这似乎在 Hemium 上偶尔会发生。
I noticed in this episode, the shot of the TV during the Yosemite Sandy bit.
我在这一集中注意到优胜美地桑迪期间电视的镜头。
There's a VHS tape of mad TV showing.
有一盘疯狂电视节目的 VHS 录像带。
Is this a planned homage to mad TV or coincidence?
这是有意向疯狂电视致敬还是巧合？
That's a coincidence.
这是一个巧合。
I don't know why that was there.
我不知道为什么那儿在那里。
But I do want to say something about that bit, which is that I think that that bit is from because Chris Harris wrote the episode and that actual idea of putting a little mustache or whatever on the TV screen was I think from a story from his wife, Chris's wife, Hillary, She's also our friend and a very funny person or a fun writer.
但我确实想说一些关于这一点的事情，我认为那一点是因为克里斯·哈里斯写了这一集，而在电视屏幕上放一点小胡子或其他什么的实际想法是我认为来自他妻子的故事，克里斯的妻子希拉里，她也是我们的朋友，一个非常有趣的人或一个有趣的作家。
And she, her friend group or some friend group in college that I think may have included Paul Giamatti.
她，她的朋友团体或大学里的一些朋友团体，我认为可能包括保罗·吉亚玛蒂（Paul Giamatti）。
She was in the same area as Paul Giamatti and Yell.
她与保罗·吉亚玛蒂和耶尔在同一地区。
I think it may have been part of his friend group would do this, would put a mustache on the TV.
我认为可能是他的朋友团体的一部分会这样做，会在电视上留小胡子。
And when it would like line up perfectly with someone, there'd be like cheers, maybe it was a drinking game, but it was a real thing.
当它想要与某人完美地排成一排时，就会有人欢呼，也许这是一场饮酒游戏，但这是真实的事情。
And Chris talked about in the room, we said, they're going to do that.
克里斯在房间里谈到，我们说，他们会这么做。
They're going to do that to Sandy Rivers.
他们将对桑迪·里弗斯这样做。
I think all the variations, the idea that it was Yosemite Sandy was probably something we we came up with, but it was, we stole this bit from real life, like many an absurd bit.
我认为所有的变化，即优胜美地桑迪的想法可能是我们想出来的，但事实上，我们从现实生活中偷走了这一点，就像许多荒谬的东西一样。
It's so fun to be a writer, because every little random dorm room memory is admissible.
成为一名作家真是太有趣了，因为宿舍里的每一个随机的记忆都是可以接受的。
Yeah.
是的。
Like it actually helps your job.
就像它实际上对你的工作有帮助一样。
Yeah, it's admissible in court.
是的，法庭可以接受。
Yeah.
是的。
It does, and you have, I think half the job being a writer, maybe 80%, is like 83%, is being a sponge, right?
确实如此，我认为作为一名作家，一半的工作，也许是 80%，大约 83%，就是成为一块海绵，对吧？
It's like just sponging up details and going, this is gonna come out somehow.
就像只是吸收细节然后继续，这会以某种方式出现。
And having recall for them at the right moment.
并在适当的时候召回他们。
Having recall, yeah, this fits.
回想起来，是的，这很合适。
this moment.
此时。
That's Chris Harris.
那是克里斯·哈里斯。
Very good at that.
非常擅长这一点。
So for a final question.
最后一个问题。
Here's a another category of a big question here from Yasmine Zachary.
这是 Yasmine Zachary 提出的另一个大问题。
This episode plays with perception.
这一集玩的是感知。
Ted believes Mary is a prostitute, Robin pretends she doesn't care, and everyone's acting instead of just being honest.
泰德认为玛丽是妓女，罗宾假装她不在乎，每个人都在表演而不是诚实。
So here's what I want to ask.
这就是我想问的。
How much damage do we do to our relationships when we make assumptions instead of asking the hard questions?
当我们做出假设而不是提出尖锐的问题时，我们会对我们的人际关系造成多大的损害？
And why is pretending always easier than being vulnerable.
为什么假装总是比脆弱更容易。
Wow, that's, uh, it's like smart question.
哇，这是，呃，这是一个聪明的问题。
It's, it's great.
真是，太棒了
It's totally above our pay grade to answer this, but let's try.
回答这个问题完全超出了我们的工资水平，但让我们尝试一下。
That's like a great question to ask of like an actual expert.
这就像一个像真正的专家一样提出的好问题。
My wife would be able to answer that question.
我的妻子能够回答这个问题。
Yeah, I was just going to say, it sounds like a question Jordana would ask.
是的，我只是想说，这听起来像是乔丹娜会问的问题。
I read a really interesting article on Substack that was like, don't let your life be guided by movie logic.
我在 Substack 上读到一篇非常有趣的文章，内容是，不要让你的生活被电影逻辑所引导。
And essentially what it was saying, like most plots in a movie are because people won't have hard conversations or uncomfortable conversations.
从本质上讲，就像电影中的大多数情节一样，人们不会进行艰难的对话或不舒服的对话。
Like, you know, Goodwill Hunting could have stopped him and was like, you know, you seem like a really smart guy, but your anger is getting in the way of your moving forward.
就像，你知道，善意狩猎本可以阻止他，就像，你知道，你看起来是一个非常聪明的人，但你的愤怒阻碍了你前进。
Like if someone had just like said these things, I mean, obviously you wouldn't have a movie to watch and that wouldn't be good.
就像如果有人说了这些话，我的意思是，显然你不会有电影可看，那不会很好。
But the author was saying, don't let your own life be guided by what you see in movies, which is often talking around things, miscommunication.
但作者想说的是，不要让你自己的生活被你在电影中看到的所引导，这往往是围绕着事情说话，沟通不畅。
And she did this example that I think she was in a law school or a graduate school.
她做了这个例子，我认为她是在法学院或研究生院。
And there was a woman, and I don't know if it was like a guy that they both liked or something where there was a miscommunication slash, they were at cross purposes for some reason.
还有一个女人，我不知道这是否像他们都喜欢的男人，或者存在沟通不畅的情况，出于某种原因，他们的目的相互矛盾。
And she kind of glared at her, her friend, the woman across the room, and she marched right doctor already said, look, I think we got off on the wrong foot here and there might be a miscommunication.
她有点怒视着她，她的朋友，房间另一边的那个女人，然后她向右走，医生已经说过，看，我想我们在这里走错了路，可能存在沟通不畅。
I would really like to hash this out.
我真的很想解决这个问题。
And the woman said, oh, my God, I'm so glad you said that.
那女人说，哦，天啊，我很高兴你这么说。
I've been feeling the same thing.
我也有同样的感觉。
She said she became my like ride or die best friend, right?
她说她成了我最好的朋友，对吗？
And it's something Tim Ferris says that, that your success in life is directly proportional to the amount of uncomfortable conversations you're willing to have.
蒂姆·费里斯说过，你生活中的成功与你愿意进行的不舒服的谈话的数量成正比。
And I just had two uncomfortable conversations with people that I needed to have yesterday.
昨天我刚刚与我需要进行的人进行了两次不舒服的谈话。
And boy, last night, I couldn't have been in a better mood.
天哪，昨晚我的心情真是好极了。
I felt newly born.
我感觉自己焕然一新。
It's what starts to cause death cookies, you know, that these things that are kind of on our list that are looming that you really don't want to do.
这就是饼干开始导致死亡的原因，你知道，这些在我们的清单上的事情正在迫在眉睫，但你真的不想做。
But once you do them, it uncorks this enormous amount of life energy.
但一旦你做到了，就会释放出巨大的生命能量。
When you say the thing you feel like socially, you're not supposed to say, or you know, but when you're vulnerable, I, you know, I'm a big fan of it, not maybe in the movie writing because we still want to have movies to watch where people don't know how to do this.
当你在社交场合说出你喜欢的事情时，你不应该说，或者你知道，但是当你很脆弱时，我，你知道，我是它的忠实粉丝，也许不是在电影写作中，因为我们仍然希望有电影可以看，而人们不知道如何做到这一点。
But I think in life, it's a great idea to be as clear, you know, like Brene Brown says clear as kind.
但我认为在生活中，保持清晰是个好主意，你知道，就像布琳·布朗所说的“清晰又友善”。
I have felt terrible since you told me yesterday.
自从你昨天告诉我以来，我感觉很糟糕。
You never really liked me for 20 years, but I'm glad you slept great.
二十年来你从来没有真正喜欢过我，但我很高兴你睡得很好。
Yeah, I'm so sorry, Craig.
是的，我很抱歉，克雷格。
Just for me, it was a great relief.
就我而言，这真是一种解脱。
I'm glad it's a load off.
我很高兴这减轻了负担。
It's so true.
这是真的。
And I think what I like about, again, I think things come out, I'm realizing like, I don't And this wasn't intentional.
我想我喜欢的东西，再一次，我认为事情会发生，我意识到，我不喜欢，这不是故意的。
This is the episode where we introduced group telepathy.
在这一集我们介绍了团体心灵感应。
Maybe we introduced group telepathy because so much of the rest of the actual communication is bullshit in this episode.
也许我们引入了群体心灵感应，因为在这一集中，其余的实际交流大部分都是废话。
They're all putting on some fucking bullshit in this episode.
他们在这一集中都在胡说八道。
This question is exactly right.
这个问题问得完全正确。
And at a certain moment in the episode, they have to resort to telepathy because no one's actually saying the things.
在这一集中的某个时刻，他们必须诉诸心灵感应，因为没有人真正说出这些话。
Some people are wearing masks they mean to be wearing.
有些人戴着他们想要戴的面具。
Mary has a mask thrust on her that's not her that's not the correct mask you know She's the only person telling the truth.
玛丽戴着一个面具，那不是她，这不是正确的面具，你知道她是唯一说真话的人。
She's the only person telling the truth.
她是唯一说真话的人。
Yeah Well, that's it those are our questions.
是的，这就是我们的问题。
Thank you so much for them on Instagram and everywhere else that That you could talk to us on the on the Facebook how we made your mother fan page By the way every time I pause I say our name how we made your I'm now I trip up over over what's the name of this show is versus how I made and I write it.
非常感谢他们在 Instagram 和其他地方，您可以在 Facebook 上与我们讨论我们是如何制作您母亲粉丝页面的。顺便说一句，每次我停下来时，我都会说出我们的名字，我们是如何制作您的，现在我对这个节目的名称是什么以及我如何制作和编写它感到困惑。
Oh, it's very challenging.
哦，这非常具有挑战性。
We made this very hard on our solves, yeah.
我们的解决方案非常困难，是的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
But thank you so much for everything.
但非常感谢你所做的一切。
Keep them coming, thanks everybody.
让他们继续来吧，谢谢大家。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被宽恕了。
New York City.
纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, A.K.A.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，我们的数字内容制作人 A.K.A.
Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg, artwork by John Morrow.
Z 世代大师是艾米丽·布隆伯格 (Emily Blumberg)，约翰·莫罗 (John Morrow) 的作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our Substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
单击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you can subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 的《Muse Letters》，在 CraigThomasRider.com 斜杠小说上订购克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 的处女作，您还可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死亡父亲协会》(Dead Fathers Society)。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下才得以实现的。
People will In fact, dance.
人们实际上会跳舞。